Kaden Richards is a college-going
teenager who has it all he is good
looking is the star of the college
football team and has the hottest
girlfriend around however he holds a
dark secret which no one knows of Caden
is actually a werewolf meaning that he
can supernaturally morph into a giant
wolf on a full moon night in the opening
scene Caden and his team are seen
dismantling their opponents in a
football match because of his super
athletic abilities he is easily getting
the points for his team unfortunately
this angers the opposite Captain so he
launches an attack on Caden and breaks
his nose enraged our werewolf
protagonist retaliates and beats the guy
to a pulp shocking everyone around
except everyone who's fans of werewolves
the following night Caden takes his
girlfriend to a secluded spot and starts
making out with her in the car
coincidentally it is a full moon night
and when the cloud clears Caden starts
turning into a ferocious werewolf as
expected this terrifies the girl and
runs away from there in an instant but
we all know she's super turned on
Caden's problems continue to pile up as
the next morning he wakes up in his room
and finds that he has massacred both his
parents Kaden has completely taken aback
by the site but before he can even
process the incident his girlfriend
arrives outside with the cops this act
of betrayal infuriates Kaden so he once
again turns into a werewolf but instead
of attacking his girlfriend he uses his
superhuman abilities to escape the place
without being detected unfortunately he
is labeled a murderer all over the news
and the entire country begins looking
for him this is I'm sorry this is so
silly after evading cops the whole day
Kaden reaches another city at night
where he sees two bikers trying to
assault a girl he politely orders them
to stop but when they don't listen he
turns into his other form and finishes
them off brutally this obviously scares
the girl so she runs away from there
Kaden also realizes the damage that he
has caused prompting him to steal a bike
and Escape some hours later he arrives
at a bar and starts drinking to drown
his Sorrows meanwhile a shady looking
guy approaches him and initiates a
conversation he introduces himself as
Joe and shockingly reveals that he too
is a werewolf he further explains that
he knows about Caden's secret as well
according to Joe there are many
werewolves like them out there and many
of them have disguised themselves well
into society curious Kaden wonders how
he turned into one despite the fact that
he has never been bitten before however
Joe doesn't answer any of his questions
and prepares to leave before exiting the
bar though he leads Kaden to a certain
Town saying that he will get all his
answers there why'd I kill my parents
because you're an [__] in the next
scene Caden arrives at the said town and
enters yet another bar surprisingly all
the people there starts staring at him
among them is a menacing looking guy
named Connor Caden ignores all this and
starts flirting with the beautiful
bartender Angel but before he can get to
know her better a drunk guy approaches
him and tries to initiate shade a fight
soon his friends also join and the
situation becomes dense however Kaden
who is already a wanted criminal backs
out not wanting to cause any commotion
he leaves the bar silently but Waits
near the bushes to exact Revenge an hour
later the drunk guy also leaves and when
he is alone Caden confronts him about
the earlier incident suddenly the guy
starts changing into a werewolf he then
prepares to attack Kaden but our
protagonist seems to be simply too
powerful he beats the hell out of the
drunk guy making him pee his pants just
like a werewolf do after this as Kaden
reaches his bike an old man suddenly
shows up he introduces himself as John
and offers the boy a job at his farm
Caden who is desperate for a place to
live immediately accepts the offer from
the next morning he starts working on
the farm and gives it his all it appears
as if Kaden is finally going to turn a
corner but one morning the menacing
looking guy from the bar Connor shows up
he confronts Jon and inquires why he
appointed a strange for the job in
response the old farmer lies that the
boy is his nephew Connor doesn't believe
this and also mentions that his friend
was beaten up by Kaden but the duo
denies this seemingly out of questions
Conor leaves but he warns the boy that
he will keep an eye on him that night as
Kaden is heading to the bar a guy
suddenly approaches him claiming that he
is his nephew he also warns Kaden that
he should leave town as soon as possible
because if Conor finds out about his
real identity he will be killed the guy
then proceeds to introduce himself but
right then Connor shouts from afar this
frightens the guy and he quickly runs
away while a confused Caden enters the
bar and starts chatting with angel angel
is just so hot later we see that Conor
and his gang have captured the guy and
are questioning him in the middle of the
woods they ask what he said to Caden
earlier but the guy doesn't open his
mouth out of fear enraged Connor decides
to play a brutal game he orders the guy
to run into the woods and after a few
seconds the entire gang starts chasing
after him elsewhere as Caden is return
turning home on his bike he hears the
guy screaming for help he quickly
decides to help and enters the woods
where he surprisingly comes across Angel
it turns out she also followed the gang
after hearing the noises the two then
ventured deep into the woods and come
across a gruesome sight Conor and his
gang have killed the guy and are now
devouring him bit by [__] this reveals
that all of them are werewolves Angel
who is used to such incidents in the
town doesn't even Flinch but Kaden is
disgusted and he throws up to his
surprise Angel already knows that he is
a werewolf too I love werewolves
following this the two return a home
where Jon and his wife Clara are
watching the news about Caden's apparent
murders realizing that his cover has
been blown Kaden apologizes and prepares
to leave but right then Clara hugs him
tightly saying it's not your fault then
Jon steps forward and dishes out a
shocking Revelation he explains that
Caden's mother Tina was a pure-blooded
werewolf from this very Town her
enchanting looks and warm personality he
made all the men fall in love with her
and Connor was no exception he asked
Tina to be his wife and when she
declined he forced himself onto her and
made her pregnant this is how Kaden was
born but afraid of the backlash Tina was
hidden in the basement and Caden was
given up for adoption to a loving couple
a month later Tina couldn't bear the
pain anymore and she committed the
unthinkable the news eventually reached
Conor and he became more violent and bit
a lot of humans turning them into
werewolves now he operates a large gang
and his only mission is to breed with
the only pure-blooded female in town who
happens to be Angel and who wouldn't
want to breed with her you know what I'm
saying oh
John further explains that the
werewolves are of two types pure blood
and hybrid Caden is one of the
pure-blooded ones and this explains why
he is so strong on the other hand the
hybrid wolves are much weaker hearing
all this Kaden is left speechless but he
finally understands how he became who he
is today some time later Kaden along
with Angel head to the barn where they
continue their conversation the latter
reveals that she is voluntarily going to
offer herself to Conor so that the
brutality can come to an end and also
because she just wants that werewolf D
however Kaden is totally against it this
is because he has started to Harbor
feelings for her surprisingly In the
Heat of the Moment they end up making
out Caden turns into a werewolf because
werewolves are really just a clever
metaphor for boners but even this does
not stop the two from having coitus once
they are done a reinvigorated Kaden
heads to Conor's Hideout and confronts
him he reveals that he is Tina's son and
warns Conor to stay away from Angel
unfortunately the evil werewolf doesn't
believe it and he instead sends his men
after the boy with this an intense fight
in Susan the woods and Kaden who is a
pure blood takes down on all the hybrid
wolves one after another but just when
he is about to emerge Victorious Conor
arrives there in his deadly wolf form
and attacks him at last Kaden is
overpowered and cornered and in order to
save himself he has no choice but to
jump off a cliff this breaks almost all
the bones in his body and just when it
appears as if he is going to pass away
Joe suddenly arrives and urges him to
get up Kaden who is still in a State of
Shock slowly gets to his feet but when
he looks around no one is there it turns
out that he was uh hallucinating earlier
Caden then staggers on for a while until
Angel arrives there and rescues him the
next morning we see him lying in bed
with bruises and cuts all over his body
John asks him to turn into a werewolf as
it is the only way to heal but Caden is
unable to do so hence Angel Springs into
action and kisses him once again
arousing the werewolf inside his body
the plan works and all the bruises on
his body instantly start healing
following this Kaden along with the help
of John starts plotting to finish off
Conor once and for all they head to the
warehouse and prepare some explosives
which they then seal inside of bags and
bury in the fields the plan is to summon
Conor and his gang near the explosives
and blow them up at the right moment
later as Kaden is busy in the field he
suddenly hears Angel screams terrified
he immediately rushes inside the house
only to realize that Conor is kidnapped
her along with Jon Clara and their
daughter he is also left a note which
invites Kaden to The Mating ceremony
between Connor and Angel that night in
the next scene we see that it is a full
moon night and the ceremony has already
begun John and his family are locked
inside a cage while Angel is brought out
on a wooden stretcher Connor excitedly
looks at her ready to have vigorous
intimacy just then two of his henchmen
are attacked nearby and killed it is
none other than Kaden who has arrived in
his most deadliest form Caden
immediately orders his men to attack him
but all of them are of no match an
enraged Caden single-handed defeats all
of them before freeing angel from her
shackles surprisingly due to the full
moon she too turns into a werewolf and
starts attacking the other hybrid Wolves
at an opportune moment she then frees
Jon and his family from the cage before
fleeing into the woods later Cade
manages to lure the bad guys into the
farm where Jon is already waiting with a
rifle in his hand as per the plan he
shoots at the mines and blows up the
ground killing some of the werewolves in
the process unfortunately this only
infuriates Conor and he goes on a
rampage to find the culprits when he
spots Kaden in the barn he immediately
enters inside with his men but
unbeknownst to them this was only a trap
Cadence securely exits through another
door and seals the entire Barn trapping
Conor and his men inside then John
shoots at one of the explosives inside
blowing up the entire place this is
enough to kill all the henchmen but
Conor remains unscathed have you seen
these abs impenetrable following this an
intense fight between Kaden and Connor
the two both being pure-blooded
werewolves match each other's stride for
stride and dish out brutal punishments
on each other but in the end it is Kaden
he comes out on top due to his sheer
determination to avenge his mother and
all the loved ones that have been taken
from him as Conor lies on the ground
injured and defeated he reveals
something shocking it turns out that he
and Tina were actually in love with each
other and they made romance with mutual
consent however after Tina's death her
father became enraged and spread false
rumors that Conor forced himself onto
her Kaden is left stunned by the
information and as he is contemplating
on what to do next the Shady got from
earlier Joe suddenly appears freaking
Joe everybody with a grin on his face he
reveals that this was all his plan when
he learned if Kaden's whereabouts he
killed his adoptive parents and lured
him into this town he then manipulated
the boy into starting a war with Conor
and ultimately killing him Joe reveals
that he did all of this because he
wanted to exact revenge on Conor who
and exiled him from the town since he
was not strong enough to do so he turned
to Caden hearing all this Caden becomes
enraged and tries to attack Joe but he
is quickly knocked out then the evil guy
proceeds towards a weakened Connor and
finishes him off with a deadly claw to
the throat after this he proceeds to
strangle Caden to death but before he
can complete the task Jon shoots him in
the hand this forces Joe to retreat
however he cannot reach far as Caden
tackles him to the ground the two
werewolves then face each other in an
intense stare down Joe pulls out a
cigarette and starts smoking but Caden
quickly throws it to the ground and
backs away smoking kills
surprisingly turns out to be a part of
the plan as there is a mine directly
beneath Joe the cigarette ignites it and
by the time Joe catches wind of this it
is already too late the next second he
is blown to Smithereens finally bringing
an end to the chaos the movie ends is
Kaden and Angel depart the town the
following morning hoping that they can
find the other pure-blooded werewolves
and Unite with them but let's be real
who cares if they find the others
they're going to make sweet werewolf
love for the rest of their lives
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching